the Joe Rogan experience those days you
do I just went to a food truck before I
got here and there was an Asian girl and
like my favorite kind of Asian girl she
was a bleep Filipino big lips tan dark
tan with daisy dukes
oh my open-toed sandals beautiful feet
nice pedicure we freaking out it was it
was just me and her so I couldn't stare
and it was so painful you were like
you're fighting your neck like don't
[ __ ] turn keep your head straight
here's what's interesting and this is
the dynamic there's a difference she men
and women if we were just describing
it's the exact same thing but you were a
girl and you were describing a guy it
would be innocent yeah it would be
nothing
it wouldn't be creepy it'd be like that
girl's so horny oh my god like if she
was like I was in line and behind me was
Jason Momoa you know Aquaman
oh my god if you think he looks good in
movies he looks so good in real life
sweetie I couldn't stop I was looking
right at his dick I looked at his dick
and I looked his face I look at this
dick and he starts smiling and then I'd
start nodding
and no one would care no and you say
that girl's liberated she's free she's
crazy
there goes wild if she could maybe grab
it on the way out tell ya let me give a
little tap tap tap no one's gonna call
the cops right but if that's the
difference and that's I think this is
something that as men this is a shaky
one because there are definitely some
fake male feminists out there that are
just doing it because they want women to
love them mm-hmm and they say a bunch of
[ __ ] that really screws the curve up but
if you're being honest and you're being
rational you have to realize that the
way a woman perceives being hit on is
gonna be way different than the way a
guy does cuz the girls in danger
she's in potential danger like
legitimately yeah like if you or some
[ __ ] serial killer psychopath and you
decided to follow her back to her house
that's on the menu that's on the menu
how rare is it that you meet a girl
somewhere in she wants to come back to
your house and kill you yeah pretty
[ __ ] well yeah Aileen Wuornos that
monster for the Charlie's the wrong
movie oh yeah that girl did prostitute
she would shoot pick guys up and
they would think they were gonna go get
laid and she'd kill him right and they
were all so it wasn't you know people
can demonize the the John because he's
picking up a right hard worker because
sex they see it's not victimless yeah
but you know he just wants sex he
doesn't want you murdered you know but
she was tortured and you know abused so
horribly in her life that men became the
enemy yeah there's a big lesson in that
man I've known guys and watched them as
they got older and like failed
relationship after failed relationship
where they started to developing this
like resentment towards women you know
this is like a deep-seated like [ __ ]
them all they want is this and all they
want to because what they're getting
from the women all the time is negative
they're getting rejection because
they're trying to get laid they didn't
want the women that touch them and the
women are like I'm not really into
touching you like [ __ ] these wars and
they eventually develop this thing where
they just hate isn't there a name for
those guys misogynists no there's like
an online so yeah insults or guys who
the I think mostly they're talking about
like like a lot of those guys are like
genetically unfortunate yeah [ __ ] up
bones truck and butt and that's why
there's an argument for legalized
prostitution because there are men that
just because of deformities or whatever
reason or maybe they're maybe they're
even neurotic dude where they can't hit
on a woman and so there should be a
place where a woman can knowingly and
confidently and safely be a prostitute
yes yes it should be your option the
problem is we equate prostitution with
to things that are horrible sexual abuse
and sex slavery sex trafficking we we we
equate prostitution with those things
that's why like when Robert Kraft got
busted one of the first things they said
is this guy's a billionaire and he was
participating in sex trafficking that's
they accused him of but then they had to
drop that I don't know if you know that
now so there was no sex trafficking
there there was prostitutes there was
women who wanted to have sex for money
and they weren't they can come over in a
sealed tanker and slept in though no
they were prostitutes yeah you know and
it's their their choice and they you
don't hear much about that the
the sex trafficking was like a big thing
I think to get him to plead guilty and
they put it out there and they they said
you know they were shaming him and
making it this big deal this guy I paid
to get his dick touched you know and
here he is what is he like 78 years old
80 years old or something like that
this old guy just want to get his dick
touched he paid it was a deal's a deal
she probably did it 13 times that day
before him you know that's what they
were doing in that place there were
jerking guys off but people kept coming
back why they keep coming back because
they hated it why they keep coming back
cuz it was a ripoff why they keep coming
back no because as adults they wanted to
get their dick touched and this woman
was willing to do that and she yeah
isn't that a bad job it's a [ __ ]
terrible job so is Wendy's so is being a
dishwasher those are terrible jobs - do
you want to do you want to be the guy
who puts the coal the the [ __ ] tar
and the streets and the hot day do you
want to be that guy yeah the [ __ ] out of
here that job sucks do you want to be a
guy who works in a gas station we've
constantly sniffing fumes [ __ ] that that
job sucks LA job suck that's your choice
it's your choice as a human being to
take that job or not take that job I
feel the same way about prostitution I
feel about massage it's like if you can
pay someone to touch your feet and rub
your feet you can pay a dude to just be
rubbing your feet
why can't you pay someone to touch you
why can't anyone touch your genitals and
like you said you'll get rid of the
stigma by legalizing it and making sure
those girls right I've been to the bunny
ranch I got a tour I went you know my
wife gave me permission I had a map I
had a [ __ ] Hawaiian shirt on no I had
the t-shirt with the tour dates I he
died recently Dennis HOF Dennis HOF died
yes sir he invited me he came to a show
I was doing in Lake Tahoe
I know Reno and he goes hey do you want
to come take a tour and like because of
the stern connection I kind of knew him
so do you want to come take a tour of
the ranch and I go let me call my wife
and then I called her and I go can I
just I go I just want to see it just
gonna smell it and she goes well if you
bring Kathleen roll who is the feature
act with you then you can go so they
send a limousine we go off and we walk
in and there was like one room had like
a
[ __ ] trap he's in it and the other
one had a hot tub they all had different
like themes to them and it was like it
wasn't a skanky as I thought but it was
pretty down and dirty was like trailers
but they were clean and while I was
there a doctor showed up and they gave
them all [ __ ] they check their
snatches for whatever what they had a
little kitchen add they'd somebody
cooking little snacks for them they
offered me some I said I'm gonna pass
and then at the end he pulls me aside he
goes by the way Greg take any of the
girls it's on the house and I go well
Dennis I've never been with a prostitute
before and it wasn't because of the
hundred bucks I wasn't waiting for a
freebie and but the girls were they were
happy they keep 50% of the money they
can't use drugs on the premises they
they can refuse a customer and they come
and go and they want I think people
should be able to do whatever they want
that doesn't hurt people and I think
that that falls into that category and I
think it does provide a service for
really frustrated men they can't get sex
any other way yeah and I think it's
stigmatized I think it's stigmatized in
a very weird way it's not a good job I
don't want to do it I don't want my
children to do it I don't want your
children to do it
I don't want my kids to work as a
dishwasher either I don't want my kids
to be a coal miner those things are real
jobs you know I just don't I think that
if we had different attitudes about sex
we wouldn't look at it as harshly we
would look at it as horribly as we look
at it we look at it different because we
think they like intimacy is connected to
romance and romance is connected to this
emotional connection you have with this
person that you're sharing pleasure with
like that's that is wonderful but
physical release is also very important
for men it's like it's very important to
and it's very important for everyone to
be touched and some people people don't
want to touch them you're just not doing
so good yeah it's just they're not in a
good spot they don't they're not
physically attractive whatever it is
whatever the whatever for some people
and they have a desire and a need to be
touched and it [ __ ] wrecks them to
the soul when they're not touched all
the time they constantly walk around
filled with resentment filled with
bitterness if we just quietly enraged
inside at the hand that lie
has given them and for those people if
you had legalized prostitution if it was
like someone who liked you you could
conceivably have friendships with these
people that you're having sex with if
you wanted to do that like I knew a girl
who when she was younger she was a sex
worker and she's uh
I won't even reveal her it would be too
obvious if I reveal what she does but
she did it for a while when she was like
young and she [ __ ] some older guys
they were like you know in their sixties
and [ __ ] they didn't know you know they
had money but they didn't have the time
to date and you know maybe they had a
wife and they wanted have sex with
somebody on the side and she would take
money from them she liked it she's like
it's a great way to make money it was a
lot more money it's not that big a deal
she was I knew who I was doing it with
and I was like wow she's smart you know
I mean I don't think everybody has that
attitude and I would never want anybody
to do that that doesn't have that
attitude but if you're one of those
girls it's like hustling maybe you don't
have a family that backs you up there's
girls that like you know they're in kid
there is legitimately like there's the I
got a friend who's really wealthy and
his friends have some of them have like
a girl in New York and they pay for her
apartment and she's going to college and
he goes to New York seven eight times a
year and when he does she frees her
calendar and goes out to dinner with him
goes to wherever he sleeps there they
have sex and it's a comfortable working
relationship so I don't know where's the
where's the problem with that who's the
victim right yeah he's a sugar daddy
yeah yeah I don't I think we have crazy
attitudes for finite beings we have this
crazy attitude like we're leaving this
permanent like ledger of all the moral
and immoral things we've done especially
when it comes to sex so it's just sexy
[ __ ]
yeah it's great everybody wants it but
everybody doesn't get it and everybody
sometimes people get rejected so it
carries all this weight and so it's just
like a bit and then you're not supposed
to do it cuz God doesn't want you to or
you could get pregnant Jesus Christ you
pro-life or you pro-abortion he pro
woman's like to choose you didn't even
you should even have a say you have a
[ __ ] penis like whoa charge yes so
charge right and meanwhile biologically
your brain is going no no no we got
[ __ ] okay I got loads building up I
gotta get rid of these things
mm-hmm you know like I used to have a
bit called jerk-off first and think
about it was my advice for everything
because there's so many moments in life
when you jerk off first and then you go
what's what was definitely not responded
that crazy [ __ ] letter she sent me
yeah in the mail yeah you know when you
get a letter from somebody like oh no
it's like sobering up yeah
jerk off first jerk jarasand know your
real intentions if you jerk off first
and you still want to call someone you
really care about them you love them
that's right it's not just lust yeah
that's it that's empty bag think yeah
yeah I I was never good at that like
I've reset the clock one nowadays I pop
give you 24 hours did leave me a little
25 24 hours
[Applause]